hugh jackman he smell that smells like
Oscar bait good joke
hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I
imagine haze and your age you should go
check out his movie review channel as
soon as you can actually just don't
watch this video just subscribe to me
Shh I know this guy he's a funny man was
a handsome man let's say I'm pretty
handsome
Andrew cut the cockiness who's your
favorite superhero I don't know for Hugh
Jackman I know you love the hell out of
this guy amazing movie the front runner
you know who really requested this
patron of the day shout out garage
Krishnan you like our Patriot right he's
a patriot
I'm a patron I got a full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A garage Trish Nana's
always requesting the best the best the
best kind of trailers out there he has
one handsome devil and if there was
anyone for a front-runner for best
patronage act it would be uh Matt dear
Matt Peters Matt beer none of you not
your garage and not you Andrew Matt beer
hasn't been a patronage act for a while
- screw you Matt beer Niraj and Andrew
who are the best I'm still your friend
Matt sorry I'm sorry for the weird shout
out of Raj you deserve better
we all do campaign trip the clear
front-runner so start with the shoulder
in a little my name's Gary Hardin I'm
running for president yeah I want you to
think about the opportunity that we have
right here right now
I've never known a guy more talented at
untangling politics so that anyone can
understand it is a gift and he wants to
share that along but he wants is for him
to take just stupid folder you'll never
understand
if we hold ourselves to those highest
standard in the voters cannot do
otherwise I wanna ask you some questions
about the woman in your townhouse can
you tell us Bill Bergey series no wonder
staying in my home there's no need for
that
[Music]
to say you do embarrass me we can't hide
from this hold these guys account some
other paper use gossip as front-page
news and that doesn't mean we and that
take certain responsibilities we need to
say something it's nobody's business
none of it is okay what we're not
talking about that you're talking about
how you get through today
this campaign is about the future not
rumors not sleeves and I care about the
sanctity of this process whether you do
or do not
[Music]
go on Harry see it there's gonna be a
story tomorrow about me okay poster
that's a cool photo oh damn Wow I don't
know this story obviously I want to know
more because I mean it'll spoil the
movie if you learn I mean it makes me
intrigued from the title from what the
trailer does seem like this guy was
going to be the President of the United
States but then personal life stuff got
in the way real thing and I never even
heard of this guy I'm gonna be a hundred
percent honest yeah I've never heard of
this guy something like this should be
more well-known yeah cuz it seems like
something like someone was going to be
present and something like this kind of
scandalous well the tagline is Gary Hart
was going to be President said he'd
changed American politics forever it
makes me think about how when I would
hear about stuff like Kennedy's being
involved with like Marilyn Monroe or how
that didn't really seem to have an
effect on their political it seems like
around the for what the movies
communicating to mean it could be very
wrong and sound very stupid right now
from what the trailers communicating to
me this was a very important election
because this movie will represent how
your personal life is like going off
about like this campaign is about the
future not rumors not sleaze not care
about the sanctity of this process
whether you do or do not is what
affected him becoming president yes
personal life stuff is the thing that
affected him becoming president not
really his political views and the
betterment of the nation I always
associated that it always did play a
factor yeah but it seems like they're
saying this specific election was when
it really yeah I mean really know who
was president or who became president
instead of him yeah it was 1988 I
believe it said I'm not like too
familiar on who was president of that
Bush it might have been before we sound
dumb 1988
President Reagan Ronald Reagan yeah
Ronald Reagan not Bush Ronald Reagan was
president I've always been a fan of
Ronald Reagan you yeah you always been a
fan I mean you're a fan all right I've
always liked them back to the day I went
to like his museum oh yeah so do we
that's where I learned if a woman is
walking down the stairs you should walk
in front of her and if she's walking up
the stairs you she walk behind her in
case you fault in either one that's what
I ever remember from your on the actual
Reagan airplane you Jacque I'm good
Jacques was a great guy but you know
there's always this which may be a
frontrunner for the Oscars this seems
like the kind of movie you would get a
nomination for this is most amor like
the jason reitman films i don't allow
people prefer like the Tully's and the
Junos but I personally like the more
political based ones that he does
something like thank you for smoking
something like up in the air yes like
men moving in shorter being the two
episodes of The Office that he did yeah
there's a huge Casa de Vera Farmiga who
was in up in the air as well yeah and
Condren I mean you got syrup yeah none
out this weekend
JK Simmons looks crazy got Alfred Molina
bill bill burrs in here I can't sir
there's a huge cast like George himself
it's even have like a lot of comedic
actors for this film that is very much
not a comedy at
this seems like it could be an important
film I wonder how much but this is
actually gonna be fact you know there's
always that thing when these bodies come
out of how much is real and how much
yeah definitely I'm very interested it's
funny to me is that it's based in 88 but
it shot like a 70s movie yeah the
directing style definitely I mean it
doesn't seem like this year is going to
be tough
close like race for best actor but who
knows maybe maybe Hugh Jackman could
squeeze something yeah man he's great at
playing Americans dude should never play
Australian he's so good at playing
Barry's great Americans and Canadians
yeah there you go but even as a Canadian
he's doing an American accent yeah what
I love too about Hugh Jackman's career
especially after the success of the
greatest showman because that made me
really happy for him yeah it was that
thing of oh now he's done being
Wolverine will he ever have another
success so after the greatest show man
you're like oh yeah this guy will be
just fine yeah I keep you have to worry
about him not having a career even
seeing this I'm not going Wolverine you
know you are I'm not I'm their dad
wanting to see this portrayal you know
III definitely I mean Hugh Jackman is
personally my favorite actor so I just
want to see as much as him him as I can
yeah no matter what the rule is I'm
excited for this movie man this looks
like an important film just I hope it
doesn't suck I don't think it will all
right jason reitman everyone survive
doesn't do a great film but I think
majority of the Wrightman credentials
are pretty solid as long as they're
above 50 there you go
all right guys well thanks for watching
who do you think should be the next
president not Gary Hart apparently no
the rock obviously you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons go to kind of pointless and you
can check us out on patreon where we got
full-length TV show reactions of weekly
Q&A is more importantly fall Andrew the
haze on his YouTube channel Andrew Hayes
it's worth your time worth my time not
worth his time yeah go check it out